[Music]
it's the birth control pill you know
don't underestimate the significance of
the birth control pill it's like the
hydrogen bomb or that or the computer
chip it's a world revolutionary
technology and for all we know it might
do us in you know I mean in the West the
birth rate is far below replacement and
you know that's as a has a
multi-generational strategy that's just
that's an absolute dead end and of
course no one can talk about that
because well for for obvious the obvious
reasons of egalitarianism and diversity
and all of that but the declining
birthrate in the West is really I would
say a catastrophe
I I don't happen to be one of those
people who think the planet has too many
people on it you know so